[Music]
Adel Mahmoud:
It's one thing to say, I
have a vial of vaccine.
Adel Mahmoud:
And it's another to say,
how can you implement a
Adel Mahmoud:
vaccination program?
[Music]
Adel Mahmoud:
Princeton University's approach
to global health is
Adel Mahmoud:
based on a very, very clear vision.
Christina Paxson:
It really does bridge science
into social science into
Christina Paxson:
public policy in a way
that very few other
Christina Paxson:
institutions can do.
And if you really want to get a
handle on these issues, you
Christina Paxson:
need to have all of that together.
The subject matter demands it.
Christina Paxson:
This multidisciplinary focus is not
just nice, but essential.
Joao Biehl:
One of the hallmarks of our program is
experiential learning.
Joao Biehl:
Learning from local communities,
learning from
Joao Biehl:
interventions on the ground.
[Music]
Joshua Oppenheimer:
When I came to Princeton
I knew that I was
Joshua Oppenheimer:
interested in medicine.
And I also knew that I was
interested in politics.
Joshua Oppenheimer:
But I never really put
them together.
Joshua Oppenheimer:
I've been able to learn about
how Medicaid programs can
Joshua Oppenheimer:
better set up their design;
how Congress is trying to
Joshua Oppenheimer:
address health care at
the national level.
Joshua Oppenheimer:
And I've also been able to
learn how the Mexican
Joshua Oppenheimer:
government is trying to address their
health policy issues.
Yolisa Nalule:
I took Professor Biehl's class,
Medical Anthropology.
Yolisa Nalule:
That class and the way he taught
us to view the world of
Yolisa Nalule:
health was the eye opener.
It was that ah-ha moment that
you get when you're like, "This
Yolisa Nalule:
is what I want to do."
I came up with my summer
internship which I designed to
Yolisa Nalule:
go to Uganda and look at how
doctors, nurses, NGOs --
Yolisa Nalule:
all these organizations that
had HIV/AIDS drugs and were
Yolisa Nalule:
giving them out to people -- how
they're dealing with the
Yolisa Nalule:
issue of drug resistance.
[Music]
Christina Paxson:
Leaders in global health need
to have a broad perspective.
Christina Paxson:
We live in a world where
societies are aging.
Christina Paxson:
Health issues are really
coming to the fore.
Christina Paxson:
We can launch students into
careers where they can make a
Christina Paxson:
difference doing something that's
really, really important.
Yolisa Nalule:
The one thing Princeton has taught me is giving
back and service.
Yolisa Nalule:
And the way I can do it is
in the field of health.
Yolisa Nalule:
I will not rest until health
is a human right.
[Music]